hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven ways to keep a positive
mindset no matter what problems you have
so as you guys know entrepreneurship is
toughest one of the hardest things you
ever gonna do in your life and there's
so many ups and downs in writing the
business that if you lose your
positivity if you start to get negative
then it's gonna be really really hard to
keep your business going because you
need to be that force you need to be
that positive person that's infecting
others to go and do this impossible
thing that nobody thought was possible
to do right you need to have that
positivity because if you give up
everything crumbles so today I'm going
to talk about seven ways that you guys
can use to stay positive
even when there's craziness and crap
happening all around you
so number one is belief no surprise
coming for me it's important to believe
in what you're all about and believe in
the mission and believe breaks down to
me is believe in what you're doing so
have passion write whatever project
you're working on you need to believe in
it you need to have the passion behind
that project is believing yourself
having the confidence to know that you
can do this and believe that it's gonna
work out to have the conviction to keep
going and to follow through at the end
of the day what really helps is
remembering your why what is the big
thing that you are trying to accomplish
with your business with your idea
because that can help you stay motivated
because sometimes you get so lost in the
weeds of the day-to-day grind that you
forget about the big purpose the big
mission that you're on for me
remembering why I'm doing this what the
reason is behind something that can help
you get through those hard times those
dark days so believe and remember why
you're doing this
number two is create a great environment
it's super important that you have an
environment that makes you come alive
that builds you up that lifts your
spirits that makes you believe that you
are you know the best version of
yourself and so I'm filming here in my
office you can see some of the stuff
behind me right you've got Steve Jobs
here and Howard Schultz here my parents
here and there's other famous
entrepreneurs on my wall I want to
create an environment that I walk into
and I feel enriched then I feel happy
and it's hard to walk in like I'm
working here this is my desk I'm working
here and I've got like these people
looking at me I walk into the room and
I've got these people looking at me and
it inspires me right and that's me like
you mean look at that and say that's
really stupid I don't want to have those
people in my wall that's creepy to have
these big faces up on the wall whatever
it is right that helps me and so create
an environment that makes you come alive
think about what's on the walls what's
on your computer what's on the phone
background what apps do you use right
like what's around you who are the
people in your life what books do you
read what are the videos that you watch
what are the things that are around you
that help build you to be the person
that you could be because you know the
feelin if you're around negative people
if you're watching the news all the time
you're gonna start feeling really
negative or if you're surrounded by
positive things
uplifting things resources that build
you up to give you ideas that make you
feel creative that make you have
confidence that's so much better for you
it's better for your health it's better
for the creations that you'll put out
and it's better for the world and so
don't make your environment something
that's just happens to you by accident
consciously created for yourself so
you've made an environment that helps
you be the best version of you
number three has helped someone it's
really hard to feel down to be negative
to have a bad attitude when you're
helping somebody else out and so a great
way out of the doldrums is to help
somebody it could be somebody in your
business it could be a customer could be
a partner it could be an employee it
could be you know supplier but it could
be somebody on the street it could be
the person behind you you know in
Starbucks pay for their coffee right and
just something holding the door for
somebody something where they would
appreciate it could be a handwritten
note to somebody doesn't have to cost
you money doesn't forgot you a lot of
money or any money it just takes a
little bit of time and a little bit of
awareness and appreciation to find
somebody in your life that you know or
you didn't you're about to know to find
a way to contribute to them in some way
that makes them feel good and when you
make somebody else feel good naturally
you just make yourself feel good even
going on the comments of this video and
responding to some of the other people
who've left comments makes them feel
good right recognize them appreciate
them thank them for their insights
that'll make them feel good but in in
that process it makes you feel good too
so if you're ever feeling down or
negative a quick way out is to help
somebody
number four is improve your habits just
like the environment that you're in a
super important so are the habits
because you are what you consistently do
so what do you consistently do do you
engage in negative habits do you engage
in things that bring you down or do you
engage in habits that are meant to build
you up so what is your morning routine
look like what is your evening routine
look like what is your schedule look
like on a day to day basis is it
something that helps build you up or you
just fall into it by accident because
you're so rushed to get through the day
right if you don't have ten minutes to
spend on creating an ideal schedule and
life for yourself or ten minutes in the
morning to Center yourself then you
don't deserve to have the great things
you don't deserve to have an amazing
life right spend the time you have ten
minutes to focus yourself and so what
are the habits that you are doing
consistently what does your day look
like consistently so for me I wanted to
have more great in the surrounding right
and so I put the habit of watching the
videos every day I made the top ten
videos and expressive videos for me
selfishly I wanted it I wanted to be
around these big-name entrepreneurs
who've done big things and I watched
them and I get inspired because it's so
easy to be complacent it's so easy to
wake up and just fall back into your
usual habit and routine we're here
I've watched somebody doing something
bigger man I got to go out and do
something bigger myself and I need that
every day because then I'm all pumped up
and excited today on Wednesday filming
for you guys jacked up super excited
tomorrow I'm gonna wake up and it's
starting all over again so I need to
have something in my morning routine to
get me fired up again to help me push
beyond my safe comfort zone to something
that makes me do something that's new
and scary and different and exciting and
so what are your habits what do you do
consistently what is your morning
routine is it engineered for you to be a
success instead of you falling into it
by accident create positive habits
number five is have accountability it
can be really hard to only be
accountable to yourself because you'll
tend to do the things that you just want
to do and not push yourself to where you
could go and I think as entrepreneurs is
especially hard cuz we don't have a boss
right yeah you have a customer who may
be pushing you on a deadline okay great
you work hard to get that deadline down
but otherwise you don't have a boss you
get to make all this injure yourself
there's nobody pushing to say hey you
could do a lot better and so having an
accountability partner having a
mastermind group having a place where
you can share your goals and have people
hold you accountable to them and even
just put it out in public post on this
video go to the comments and say some of
your goals and what you want to
accomplish within the next month what do
you have on your radar what are you
trying to accomplish right even just
posting it up makes you feel a little
bit more accountable and that's
important because you will tend to let
yourself down too much we won't let
other people down you'll show up for
that meeting you'll show up to go to
that gym class if somebody else is there
with you because their camera on you to
be there you won't let other people down
nearly as much as you let yourself down
so use that to your advantage and
partner up with people and you can help
them to write this ties into the other
point about helping each other out you
can help them stay accountable on their
goals and if you know that you're
meeting this person next week and you
you haven't done the thing you said
you're gonna do you're more likely to
bust into higher gear to make sure you
get that thing done because you don't
want to let them down and so use that
hack to help you get the stuff done that
you need to get done have more
accountability
number six is be grateful and talk about
positive habits one of the things that I
do everyday in in my team is we have a
pirate Facebook group where we talk
about three things that we're grateful
for every day so every day you log in
the Facebook and you have to add three
things that you're grateful for it may
take you two minutes to do but it's
really hard to hold gratitude in your
mind and some negative or angry thought
and some of the things we you know are
grateful for there might be a big thing
like I might be grateful for Hayden and
weeping for Nina I'm grateful for my
parents people you know live in this
beautiful city have this life that I do
and some of them are more esoteric like
I'm grateful for the Internet you know
I'm grateful that Alex brought me a
coffee today you know I'm grateful that
I have my own clothing line now I can I
can be grateful for a lot of different
I'm grateful there's a sun shining on me
today there's a beautiful day outside
right if you take a couple minutes not
just to write them down but to actually
feel it to feel the gratitude to feel
the warmth of the Sun to feel the love
of your mom to feel you know if you have
kids or pets or plants that you know
that you really love to feel that then
it's really hard to feel that gratitude
and be negative about something at the
same time it's really hard to hold that
in your head let me ask you guys one of
the things I'm thinking about doing is
doing a live stream every weekday
morning maybe ten o'clock I haven't
figured it out for 10 minutes just
expressing gratitude for me to share
through things that I'm grateful for the
same three things that I make my team do
but then for you guys also to share some
of the things that you're grateful for
you can join me on the journey and join
me in the ritual that every day we do
this together and share the things that
we're grateful for I'm thinking about
doing it as a live stream in the channel
really curious to see what you guys
think if you like that idea or not
because it's had a profound impact on me
if you look at the researcher
unhappiness it always comes down to
gratitude it's not about the money you
have with a car you have the job you
have or any of that stuff
it's about being grateful for what you
do have that's consistent across all the
research and so it's had a big impact on
me as had a big impact on my team you
know I'm always looking at how can I
help you guys how can I help the
entrepreneurs out in Michigan or Ohio or
Australia or if you guys all are from
that I can't connect with you one-on-one
to do this thing or we spend
ten minutes together expressing her
gratitude for the day let me know do you
guys want to do is I'm interesting to
you do you feel it's too fluffy BS
hokey-pokey not interested let me know
because if enough you want to do it then
then I just might do it so curious leave
that in the comments below so that's
number six be grateful and then number
seven is live here one word it's super
important that you know what you staying
for and that you start living it because
chances are if you are unhappy if you're
not satisfied with what's going on if
you are a negative constantly it's
because too many things in your life are
not aligned with what your one word is
all about and your one word is finding
for me it's believed but for you it's
likely something else it's figuring of
what you stand for as human being what
is the most important core value to you
it's what my book is all about what is
the most important core value to you and
then how can you build a business and a
life around it so that is congruent for
you so that doors open more easily for
you so that decisions are made more
easily understanding who you are and
what you stand for makes everything a
lot smoother and easier compared to just
reacting the things and reacting to
other people's agenda set your own and
so again if you are unhappy with
something if you're not satisfied it's
likely because too many of the things in
your life are out of congruence with
your one word you're doing too many
things that are not aligned with who you
are as a human being and so
understanding what it is that you stand
for and then building a life and a
business around it really dramatically
improves the chance of you being happy
positive but also having a huge impact
in creating something maybe even way
bigger than you thought you'd be able to
create so live your one word and if you
need help trying to figure out what that
is you can always order the book to get
read
I guarantee but even if you don't
understanding who you are what you stand
for and living a life around it will
dramatically change your life so those
are my thoughts on a seven-way so you
can keep a positive mindset no matter
what problems are around you super
curious if you're great what you guys
enjoyed about it which one was your
favorite point which one that maybe you
didn't agree with did I miss some is
there an 8 9 10 that you want to add to
the list leave your comments below and I
will join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Les Zack
bucha thank you so much for picking up a
copy
it really means a lot to me that's
support I'm so grateful and happy for
those you're watching if you want your
chance at a future shadow in the video
make sure to grab a copy of the book
really good I promise
and also emailing your receipt so you
can keep track and send you the bonuses
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon